welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and it was agatha
all along according to episode seven of
wanda vision
but despite the answers we got about
agnes actually being the witch hack of
the harkness as
always we're left with even more
questions like what is all the crap in
her dungeon what's with the cicada
and what did she do with the twins like
many basements covered in tarps bugs and
bones folks we are in
an active crime scene we are clary
starling and buffalo bill's murder
dungeon and we're gonna just have to
start shooting in the dark till we hit
something and save the children so the
lambs will stop
screaming to find these kids we gotta
break down this crime scene from the
outside in so agatha's home exterior is
actually the same house on the warner
brothers lot used for the witch
samantha's home and bewitched
covering her yard are violet flowers
with vines
radiating a purple glow visible if you
have photon powers that is
snaking down to her basement now we know
that gardening is important to agatha
well you'll notice her roses bloom under
penalty of death
i speculated in the breakdown that this
could be the wounded gore ever bloom
a plant that grows in agatha's yard in
the comics which upon consumption allows
one to see a vision of what life could
be
that is if you sob in grief and i
believe agatha here
killed sparky because he was digging it
up and maybe she's been using this plant
to drug
wanda now the basement is decorated in a
way that can only be described as
satanic
animal remains on display demonic faces
carved into the pillars hexagonal
engravings containing metallic runes
and of course a horned animal head on
the wall a goat or a ram or a yak
a curved horn animal head like this is
often associated with baphomet
a famous symbol of the occult wanda also
notices this glowing book which most of
us believe to be the darkhold
marvel's ancient evil spellbook
originally drafted by kathann
the demon who originally cursed wanda
with her sorcery in the comics
now it is here that agnes reveals
herself as the witch agatha harkness a
devious meddler behind everything wrong
in westview including all the technical
glitches that we've seen so far
since she was sitting in the director's
chair behind the camera but not in this
room are the boys
billy nor tommy so where is agatha
hiding them well remember this dungeon
exists outside the hex because the
aspect ratio shifts to that of the
outside world as wanda enters it
and these boys were manifestations of
the hex they have no corporeal outside
counterpart now agava is a witch
self-admitted warts and all so did
agatha
eat billy and tommy she did earlier
confess to cannibalism
i promise i won't bite i actually did
bite a kid once
maybe she ate them but i doubt in the
hansel and gretel cannibalistic way
remember these kids don't have actual
bodies they're essentially magic molded
into human form
so the illusory magic that created them
could get re-consumed into its source
many are pointing to the cicada wanda
spots upstairs and these similar flying
insects visible in the basement
so did agatha turn the boys into bugs
maybe but the symbolism of the cicada as
eternal lifetime dormant beings doesn't
really match up with the function of
these two
boys as we've seen them in the show
these two spend like a matter of hours
in their wombs they hatch overnight they
grow up way too fast but still i think
the cicada remains an important clue
because agave might be behind everything
but she's not working alone
she glitched her she roped pietro into
this
and dennis the mailman seems to be
another asset he now works for presto
delivery service
logo rabbit delivering something fragile
in the direction of agatha's house
now dennis himself can't be senior
scratchy remember he appeared in the
same scene in episode 2 in which agave
handed off that rabbit to wanda but they
did have this interesting exchange
stick him up don't shoot i'm just a
messenger
which now kind of looks like agatha
thinking to herself huh
i could use him now we have discussed
how the name senor scratchy could be a
nod to old scratch a nickname for the
devil or
to nicholas scratch agatha harkness's
son and i believe it is the latter that
evan peters pietro is actually agatha's
son
nicholas scratch transfigured from the
rabbits in or scratchy
to a form wanda would see as her brother
and since agatha can break the fourth
wall and see
us she recasts pietro as evan peters
from the fox x-men movies just to
with the nerds watching the show the way
deadpool a fourth wall breaker brought
in evan peters in a cameo in deadpool 2
even though that made zero sense with
that movie's timeline but uh before i
continue thanks to bang energy for
sponsoring this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero sugars and zero
artificial colors
each 16 ounce can contains 300
milligrams of caffeine
coq10 and bcaas i'm sipping on pina
colada
that nice tropical flavor that just
takes you to your happy place
but gives you the energy to fight off
any unwelcome tourist dude showing too
much skin put your shirt on
i typically pop up in a bang when i need
to pick me up in the morning or when i
need to plow through
a long video and want my mind to be
alert check out bang on instagram get 10
off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code new rockstars 10.
there you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or grab a 12 pack of citrus twist
bankster berry or the new delish
strawberry kiss
use my code new rockstars 10 to receive
off your bang energy order that's code
new rockstar's ten for ten percent off
agatha did this while sitting right
outside the window
during wanda and vision's argument in
episode five eavesdropping
wonder why are there no other children
in wizards look there are just stupid
oh no so agatha probably
suddenly populated west view with kids
in response to vision calling this out
where did she get these kids
well remember pietro told wanda that
those kids were
asleep in their beds probably where were
you hiding all these kids up till now
what
i assume they were all just sleeping
peacefully in their beds and if you
think about it that does
parallel the way cicadas rest dormantly
forever and ever and then suddenly hatch
and swarm everywhere
and now the drone kitties are being led
pied piper style back into town
and then we see dennis carrying fragile
cargo back to agatha
perhaps boxes containing the kids
reverted to cicadas once more
even if you don't buy that it's clear
that agatha glitched the drones near the
town's edge to make vision
question the reality so that he would
escape this place which would allow her
to move in on billy and tommy something
vision had previously blocked her from
doing
just maybe better not
um because remember wanda's grief is a
key component to agatha's spell that's
what pietro stated as his mo
come to town unexpectedly create tension
with the brother-in-laws draw up trouble
with the rugrats and ultimately give you
grief
that's why agatha causes wanda to see
pietro as a corpse
even though this pietro isn't the
brother who died and why she made wanda
see vision as a corpse she's trying to
keep that grief flowing and we also see
this grief stream flowing into episode
seven the opening titles mixed in this
creepy kidnapper message
i know what you are doing wanda and on
wanda's milk carton there's this missing
kid photo a kid who
looks a lot like her own son billy billy
who we'll be
missing by the end of this episode it's
all to trap wanda in this paralytic
grief
and that is how agnes prize wanda's kids
from her
and in the clutches of her home billy a
telepath hears agnes and the rabbit as
quiet
because he's unable to read their
thoughts and agnes right after this
brings up her off-screen husband ralph
again
i think ralph is our mystery cameo maybe
jimmy wu's missing person
and since agnes is a witch with new
england plates
with an anniversary of june 2nd when the
salem witch trials began
who would any witch have as her husband
folks the devil
mephisto as in the comics this is based
on the boys are pieces of mephisto's
soul
unleash hell demon and they are now
being re-consumed
into their source the dark hold that is
why it is giving off this fiery glow
and why if you notice agatha redirects
wanda right as she begins to inspect
this book
but the good news is folks based on
agatha's suddenly frazzled hair it looks
like the boys put up a fight before
being converted back into hellfire and
sucked into a spell book and we're
probably not done with them either
because this episode reminded us that
wanda is a nexus being
capable of splitting reality into a
multiverse and this series will probably
end in a house of m
style event in which wanda flees into
the multiverse with these two kids but
this witchcraft is gonna leave a scar on
this reality we know it will
because mr dell inspired my part from
home months after this
is obsessed with witchcraft what do you
think it is
you know being a man of science witches
follow me at ea vos follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for all your
wanda vision queries thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you